[Music]
very simply I could not have
accomplished what I've accomplished
including my own net worth and including
job creation if I was raised in a
country where free enterprise was not
encouraged and a free enterprise was not
the order of the day wouldn't happen
there are people who legitimately can
say they're self-made that it all
themselves I went out of my way in the
book to point out the exact opposite in
my case and only my case that I was
anything but self-made I can think back
all the way to my childhood to the
people that were there that helped me
that encouraged me that stimulated me
that motivated me that picked me up when
I was down and and maybe set on me when
I got a little too full of myself so I I
make reference to self-made as it
relates to me and me alone I am NOT
self-made that is not for humility
that's just the truth I think I think a
good start is defined self-made okay
that's a good start and I don't want to
go there cuz we could spend five hours
arguing what it means in my case I know
that where I am today without question
only happened because along the way I
had any number of episodes in my life
where it weren't for the intervention of
somebody else were weren't the
encouragement whether it was my mom and
dad whether it was my wife whether it
was a professor whether it was the guy
that ran in a liquor store in Rosslyn I
go on and on and on I know each of those
episodes was a building block for where
I am today and I I go out of my way not
to determine who self-made it who's not
I think that's for each person to decide
themselves I'm I'm very comfortable
saying that I had literally
rids of thousands of people you look at
Home Depot for example I'm one of the
co-founders
why are we so successful we're so
successful principally because when you
go to a Home Depot store you feel wanted
you feel I can get help you feel like
these people care about you there's
400,000 of them they all help to make me
successful without them Home Depot would
not have been the success it is and
probably I wouldn't have been known and
probably I wouldn't have written the
book so you got to give it
look I'm not stretching I'm saying I
look at the thing objectively but again
I swear off saying who is self-made and
who's not self-made that's all well I
think capitalism will always do better
than everything else for a variety of
reasons one there's a downside in other
words nothing is certain and there's a
price to pay and failure in capitalism
you lose your business and business
doesn't succeed whatever the other thing
is I capitalism I think is a dynamic
effort that can result
Bernie author and I and Pat ferret found
at Home Depot our hard work our creative
- creativity our ability to raise the
money to start the company all those
things has resulted in 400,000 people
having great jobs today but a better
number for me we have 3000 kids and by
the way so nobody gets offended I'm 80 -
if you're under 80 - you're a kid okay
so we have 3000 kids we started working
for us fresh out of high school didn't
go to college
pushing carts and that's the entry-level
job pushing carts in from the parking
lot we have 3,000 kids today who will
multi-million is that's how capitalism
is supposed to work it's a shared effort
and the results should be shared I
happen to think we all live better they
all say in a rising tide lifts all boats
I happen to say all of us
better in this country because we have a
capitalism system a capitalistic system
underpinning the whole nation I would
say that most of us that have benefitted
mightily by capitalism I think there's a
moral obligation on our part to make
sure we bring as many to the port many
people to the party with us as we can
okay
now this is not judgemental I'm not
suggesting for a minute that what I do
is the right thing what everybody else
does is the wrong thing what I'm saying
is simply this I feel a strong moral
imperative to share my wealth I believe
in paying all the people and by the way
nobody works for me everybody works with
me and I believe that I think all those
people have a right to know the better I
do the better they're going to do both
in terms of lifestyle in terms of
remuneration in returns of a future and
and that's the moral imperative of being
in a capitalistic system where you have
succeeded I know I feel a lot better
around all the people who work with me
knowing that they have a better life
they live in a nicer home they go to
vacations that they would otherwise not
be able to afford they got educating
their kids they themselves might
philanthropically jump into the pond so
it's that simple
[Music]